first of all who are we wearing we're
wearing valentino today
i'm very excited are you like a little
i don't know raindrop or something i
love it we asked everybody this is there
any secret about the outfit anything you
had to do behind the scenes to make it
perfect not necessarily i um i think
as soon as you're comfortable and you
feel good it just kind of falls into
place i i think it's just comfort and
that's all
well you my dear have made such a name
for yourself in the horror genre what do
you love about making movies like that
um what i love about horror is that it's
pure entertainment so i think that
there's a lot of pressure that's
released on set and everybody's there
just to give people a good time so i
think that you have some of the most fun
um i guess ballsy experiences just
because you're expressing yourself the
best you possibly can to give people
that rush of adrenaline and as somebody
who loves horror and has been a fan for
a very long time it's that's another
part of it too there's a love behind it
you know i have to ask what can we tease
for scream sick
what i will say is ghostface gets
a lot
more
intimidating i just i yeah i just i just
read part of the script and it's
it just gets more and more gory and i
think that this is probably the most
aggressive and violent version of ghost
face we've ever seen which i think would
be really fun to shoot
that's a lot to say okay um hayden
panettiere back right fans think she's
going to be kind of the new mentor to
the newbies what would you say about her
return
i
i'm not even gonna try to touch on it
all i will say is she definitely has
been one of my favorite characters in
the screen franchise for a very long
time so the fact that her character
you know gets to come back and and
redeem herself is really exciting we
know courtney cox is coming back too any
worried about nev campbell i don't know
too much about the technical side of
things i actually just found out about
courtney a couple days ago okay well
exciting news yeah i think so and the
adams family adaptation what can you
tell us about this
i'm trying to think well it's just you
know it i
feel very lucky to have been able to
portray wednesday adams as a teenager
and to watch her go off into boarding
school and kind of insert herself in a
place full of outcasts where she still
remains
um an outcast in a world of outcasts is
kind of like an interesting world and
perspective to see her in and um
yeah i think it's really the thing about
wednesday is we've never seen her on
screen for such a long period of time
she's always been the one line you know
joke and so i think it's been really
interesting
doing an eight episode series and just
kind of creating a deeper emotional arc
for her and giving her a bit more range
than than she has had previously you
know it's not always just jokes to her
which is interesting i was going to ask
how do you feel this adaptation is
different from adaptations in the past
is that it that emotional
yeah i think it's just
well who is this person you know because
she now
you spend so much time with someone you
have to add layers there has to be some
sort of complexion the whole thing i
mean is would you say the whole show's
more emotional no i i feel maybe
emotional was the wrong term because
it's definitely like the not cheesy but
you know the
slapstick humor yeah it's it's adam's
family but i think it's just more um
making her more
of a human
all right i'll let you go but real quick
have you connected with christina ricci
about playing the iconic ones
yeah i did she actually joined our
series which was really incredible so i
got i got to work with her and and i
learned a lot from her i mean
in my personal opinion wednesday will
never get any better like there's no so
that's the thing about like my portrayal
too it's like okay well i'll do what i
can and just do whatever i can to you
know make sure i'm not ripping anybody
else off or doing anything but i have
immense respect for her and i think she
will always be wednesday in my eyes